Seth what up Canadian I am Canadian we
are so proud of these Canadians I just
want you to know why thank you
I just want to know like on a scale of
one to ten of Canadian niceness where
are we landing nowadays like where are
you
where am I personally or are Canadians
in general you you say I try to be nice
10:8 yeah when it's applicable I would
say yeah god bless give myself a seven
or an eight said so like father great
movie I really loved it it's endearing
your wife did an amazing job you are a
big deal but I really do care more about
your wife I'm gonna be honest with you
oh it was great she was she was she's a
great director so it was it's so like
people give you Scripture eat a lot and
your friends and family give you
Scripture eat sometimes and it's that's
the most stressful situation because if
it's bad it's like a massive bumper so
when I read the script and also like
sometimes things aren't bad they're also
just like not things that I would
personally love but and that's two
different things and some things Lauren
likes I don't love and some things I
like Lauren really doesn't like and so
when I read the script it was so nice
because I was like hey it's good so that
instantly bails me out of like a very
awkward conversation and B it's a movie
I would actually like a lot and go see
and reminds me a lot of a lot of like
the smaller movies that I would watch
like like Nicole home centres movies
like movies that I would watch when I
was starting to write movies that really
inspired me and made me want to make
movies myself you know and then and I
knew she'd be a good director cuz I she
I seen her like just work enough over
the years and then as soon as it was
happening like I kind of stepped in that
like I didn't start shooting for like a
few weeks in the movie so I the time I
was there it was like she she had she
had everyone yeah I was stepping into a
well-oiled machine
yeah and I know she was saying that she
felt a little nervous with you gonna be
the
and then if she just felt good right
away like what did you do what happened
what did you say nothing I just did what
she told me which is all I ever tried to
do as an actor yeah I think yeah I think
in like people's I think in our heads it
was gonna be weird maybe and then it
wasn't weird and then I and yeah like
and I you know I I liked the first
movies I was in had the director's wife
in them and his kids were in them and
stuff and so like it's it I work with my
friends all the time like it to me I
didn't think it would be that weird
honestly like but yeah it was it was fun
I would do it again and you're being
inducted Canada's Walk of Fame oh my god
are you excited do you feel like you're
a young legend do you feel like you're
aging what's going on in your mind Tommy
I've never seen the Walk of Fame so it's
a little abstract to me to be totally
honest I assume it's better than the
Hollywood Walk of Fame
but I it's thrilling it's amazing it's a
great honor as soon as I I saw who else
had been inducted I was like oh my god
the fact that I'm in any way associated
with those people is a true it's an
honor it's amazing I'm thrilled I can't
wait for the ceremony they do it in I
think in December in Toronto so now
that's perfect
you really gotta earn the star you they
don't just give them out you have to
agree to show up in Toronto in December
so it's yeah there is some you have to
jump through some hoops to get because
you're so vocal yes and you're awesome
on Instagram you're awesome on Twitter
itself as a star I have to tell you I
did she's a rock star but I have to ask
you I know Ariana Grande Pete Davis yeah
they were just parading their love and
we're all celebrating and you made one
little comment it was two words and it
just went viral everyone loved it um do
you think about these things going viral
there you just know
gross I was a little much but yeah I
know Pete he's you know he's a lovely
man yeah he's in love let them have
their love